gare de calcutta dans la canicule de
l'été indien
perdu dans la foule c'est trois français
il arrive de nice
repro mini voyage en bus
m passé
sa vertu
plutôt habitué des tours organisés ils
ont cette fois choisi laventure des
vacances humanitaire là où tout a
commencé il ya soixante ans dans
l'émission de mère teresa
[Musique]
vient alors l'idée de
travailler à le népal manche
[Musique]
les trois amis vont rejoindre simone qui
souffle ses 80 printemps et des dizaines
d'autres bénévoles
simone est la doyenne des bénévoles et à
ce titre elle aime accueillir les
nouveaux pendant des vacances il en
arrive tous les jours
sont catholiques mais ce n'est pas le
cas de tous les volontaires sont de tout
âges de toutes nationalités de toutes
professions et même de tout va très bien
nous a quittés on avait pensé qu' il y
aurait beaucoup moins de volontaires y
en avait beaucoup qui veulent mais pour
mère teresa non pas du tout au contraire
ça sans biscuit un indien
aujourd'hui les bidonvilles de calcutta
sont toujours là et chaque année des
centaines de volontaires s'y retrouve
ont-ils tous la force d'affronter la
misère trouve-t-il ce qu'ils sont venus
chercher
pendant trois mois nous avons suivi des
volontaires français pas à pas confronté
à une réalité parfois dérangeantes
[Musique]
dès qu'ils arrivent à calcutta les
volontaires se font enregistrer puis
rejoignent un centre de leur choix au
coeur des vidéos
parmi eux nous retrouvons famille celle
que nous avions croisé sur le quai de la
gare elle est infirmière dans un hôpital
de miss et elle prépare ce voyage depuis
des mois fanny voulait se confronter le
temps de ses vacances à la misère de
l'inde j'ai marché sur le schéma de
jeu le beurre fondu
un jour les enfants et puis il y à
simone une habituée des lieux elle
accomplit ce qu'elle appelle sa
cinquième mission depuis le décès de son
mari elle partage son temps entre la
france et kakuta
[Musique]
une grâce
de pouvoir faire ce que je fais
je me préfère la queue dans un club du
3e âge je prends chemin tout en ayant
large d être derrière cette porte prem
dame l'un des cinq centres des
missionnaires de la charité l'ordre
fondé par leur teresa ses grands
parents
peut être bien les malades c'est ce qui
a été assurée mais si bon ben je sais
pas encourage
le centre est divisé en deux parties une
pour les hommes une pour les femmes
chaque matin les bénévoles se présente à
8 heures première surprise pour fanny
personne n'est là pour les accueillir et
leur dire ce qu'ils doivent faire
j'en peux larguer
tu vois tu prends un ses tabliers parce
qu'il ya pas mal de choses à nettoyer
d'accord dans les centres les
volontaires s'organisent entre eux les
plus anciens expliquent les règles
nouveau vous vous savez ce que vous
allez faire
[Musique]
fans il est là que pour deux semaines
comme les autres elle accepte toutes les
tâches donc tu vois le rinçage ça se
fait ici tu viens d'où en france cool
moi je viens d'afrique du sud
moi je viens deux états unis
tout le monde participe à deux sous
il n'y a pas de tâche
[Applaudissements]
de tâches qui
qu'ils soient plus noble qu note
on doit tout faire
ces poules
je suis pas lâché moi rien faire me
demander ce que je vais faire même
c'est que de la lessive
c'est utile
du côté des hommes pascal son compagnon
est déjà occupée mais aussi je suis
[Musique]
pascal est informaticien il a suivi
fanny sans trop savoir à quoi s'attendre
il voulait aider c'est tout
je suis pas venu pour des queues des
vacances
je suis venu passer dans ma vie s'est
passé quelque chose et aujourd'hui je
des jeux
pascal est un rescapé un accident de
moto la plongée dans un nom commun dont
il est sorti voilà un an comme la
plupart ici il n'avait aucune expérience
dans l'humanitaire c'est le seul endroit
qui lui a ouvert ses portes sans
demander un diplôme ou une expérience
aujourd'hui
je suis pas du médical
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas mon métier du tout
en france on va vous demander des
justificatifs persie focale un même
réseau ngc
ici on nous demande derrière le
magistrat de la commune
[Musique]
ce sont eux les volontaires qui font
tourner les 5000 centre des
missionnaires de la charité à travers le
monde libre devenir libres de partir il
reste quelques jours ou quelques mois
les soeurs s'occupe des soins aux
malades discrète dans l'ombre presque
invisible c'est ce que voulait mère
teresa aidés de bénévoles elle arpentait
les bidonvilles pour aider ce que
personne ne voyait plus les miséreux des
malades les handicapés les orphelins et
mourant
l'est avec de la tension des gestes
simples leur rendre leur dignité
on
[Musique]
fanny a trouvé ses marques une fois les
tâches ménagères terminée elle s'est
rendue auprès des malades pour leur
faire profiter de son savoir-faire
d'infirmières
ont des liens avec des matelas en
plastique
avec le chaleur c'est pas terrible pour
les oscars est cette dame a là aussi des
oedèmes alors
bon bah c'est pour éviter de possibles
et faire partir un coup et puis pour le
confort à tous
je
très important ce souhait
une forme de communication je trouve
c'est pas dénoncer la chasse
mon désir tout
vous arrivez oui oui
un joueur jour j quand simone est arrivé
pour la première fois il ya quatre ans
elle n'avait aucune compétence seulement
sa bonne volonté aujourd'hui elle
connaît presque chacune des 400 femmes
qui sont accueillis dans ce centre
si j'ai un plaisir voyez elle nous car
elle donne l'impression peut-être
qu'elle retrouvait un des leurs je me
sais ce qu elle aussi pauvre femme elles
ont vécu sur des trottoirs et là elles
sont comblés
ils n'ont pas fait surtout
jugés trop âgés trop faible ou trop
folle elles ont été abandonnées par
leurs familles et recueilli par les
soeurs chaque matin depuis quatre mois
simone s'occupe de cette femme qui
souffre d'un cancer du sein elle ne peut
pas se payer un traitement et doit
attendre que la maladie fasse son oeuvre
simone lui offre son bras et son temps
marche un peu au début elle avait des
difficultés mais elle marche un peu
faut beaucoup de patience
il faut partager un moment de souffrance
simone a choisi de vivre six mois par an
loin de sa famille pour aider à sa façon
ces femmes condamnées
tous les jours les mêmes gestes j'ai
même des moments les mêmes réactions
je vais chercher pour te masser
mais que cherche ou tel cet octogénaire
mère de trois enfants il vit deux fois
grand-mère
sipa les massages d'un professionnel
mais en fait si on les soulage un peu
c'est quand j'ai perdu mon mari que je
suis parti
j'ai dit je m'en vais je pars plus loin
possible je ne peux rester je pars en
inde il faut que je m'habille pour
arriver à oublier mon chagrin il rien de
tel que d'avoir l'aube il assure même
pour les autres parce que c'est là qu'on
rencontre aussi malheureux que soi
mais même parmi les volontaires ça
allait toujours parler des malades
j'avais des volontaires qui sont là qui
sont malheureux il se cherche à me voir
qu'est ce qui pourrait faire
et je suis sûr qu'ils ne repartent pas
le coeur et les mêmes vide
à l'autre bout de la ville nous
retrouvons clair c'est l'heure de la
pause une pause dans sa vie aussi
[Musique]
en france elle est aide soignante
cette fois elle va s'occuper d'enfants
ici ils sont tous lourdement handicapé
autistes myopathe accidenté ils sont
trouvés par les soeurs dans la rue en
héros ce en pleine période de doute
claire est venu chercher ici un second
souffle et toi ce que tu as eu d'échangé
je
c'est quelque chose que faire depuis
longtemps finalement
un petit peu longtemps qui changeait
que j'ai en ce moment
tout ce système ben ali
non je sais pas quoi
ça m'énerve pas que quoi je vais pouvoir
me rendre utile
pour des gens qui ont vraiment besoin
comme les autres volontaires elle n'a
aucune compétence pour s'occuper
d'enfants handicapés
avec un simple cahier une sorte de mode
d'emploi de chaque enfant elle leur fait
répéter des mouvements aucun médecin
encadre la séance
[Musique]
caution fatalité
enfants attachants
quand nous quittons claire elle est
visiblement émue
nous avons rendez vous avec nos jeunes
catholiques
chaque été ils sont des centaines à
rejoindre calcutta c'est une sorte de
pèlerinage pour pierre-marie à 22 ans il
fait partie d'un groupe de dix étudiants
cathodique ils se sont engagés pour un
mois dans un centre pour adolescents
handicapés moteurs et cérébraux tenus
par des frères
on va écouter le premier arrivé lt
entend aller la fois
soit bien beaucoup les câlins
promenez on va aller chanter des
chansons faire du toboggan voilà on est
petit activités simples coordonnées un
petit peu d'affection et qu'ils soient
contents donc
oui les personnes mais je crois que
c'est un peu le
le charme des volontaires c'est à dire
que comme on a pas d'activités fixe les
frères les frères nous laisse autonome
et voilà il s'occupe des tâches
ménagères des tâches administratives et
puis nous on est chargé d'occuper les
enfants on essayait d'être
simplement de les aimer leur apporter un
peu de questions
[Musique]
pierre-marie l'étudiant vient
expérimentées ici la charité chrétienne
au sens où mère teresa l'entendait
servir un pauvre un enfant abandonné ou
un homme dévasté c'est servir dieu lisez
terre pierre marie a suivi le frère
thomas il y a neuf ans lui aussi était
venu à calcutta elle était alors
étudiant en médecine c'est là qu'il a
découvert sa vocation
c'est lorsqu'on a triste pour leur vie
et ça c'est le but du voyage pour moi
pour eux ce que je désire pour eux c'est
qu'une fois rentrés en france
puissent prendre en main leur propre vie
et qu'ils aient une
vraiment ils choisissent où ils sont les
pâtes fin de leur vie qu'on choisisse
pas pour
en attendant les futures zones livres
sont débordés ils ont à peine 20 ans et
se retrouve confronté pour la première
fois de leur vie à de lourds handicaps à
eux de se débrouiller seul
et lui font le à moins qu'il ait assez
de mandeure c'est assez dur parce que
temps en temps ils ont des réactions de
violence temps en temps ils sont dans
leur point il pleure on veut pas
contrôler non quand on n'a pas
l'expérience de l'enfant handicapé qu'un
handicap mental assez fort c'est assez
dur est là
il est en train d'arriver excité il est
énervé une demande la main donc
c'est le troisième jour de pierre-marie
dans le centre et il s'est déjà attaché
à quelques pensionnaires
il y as ol qui recherchent sans cesse
son contact et puis rajesh un orphelin
recueilli par le frère thomas dans une
des gares de calcutta là où il vit
rajesh se drogue depuis qu'il a 8 ans il
en a quatorze aujourd'hui quand il est
arrivé dans ce centre il souffrait d'une
blessure infectée j'étais très malade
alors je suis venu là et on m'a acceptée
je serais mort c'est que cela
jeu n'allait vraiment pas bien je ne
pouvais même plus me nourrir
je me sens bien ici ils sont tous
gentils mais je dois partir
ça fait dix jours qu'il est là il a bien
mangé et il a bien dormi il se reposait
et là maintenant il est en pleine forme
quoi ils recommencent à grossir ils
toussent plus ce qui est rageant c'est
effectivement c'est que voilà et c'est
retour à la case départ ça veut dire que
là il vaut absolument retourner à celle
de la gare pour se reprendre les shoots
et bien voilà
pierre marie veut convaincre
l'adolescent de rester y parviendra-t-il
nous lui donnons rendez vous à la fin de
son séjour
[Musique]
lorsqu'ils ont fini leurs cinq heures de
travail quotidien les volontaires ne
quitte pas totalement la misère hors du
centre celle de la rue les attend
sur le chemin de son hôtel simone longe
des bidonvilles croiser des familles
entières qui vivent sur les trottoirs
[Musique]
visages anonymes et parfois familiers
m
tu as vraiment le rythme annuel de décès
d une ancienne que je soigne et à l'obus
terre qui guérit maintenant on
retrouvait sa maison
les la mine mais nous ça fait plaisir de
voir que dans l'arrêt elle me
rencontrent elles se souviennent que je
le sois nuit
bien bon courage bien
à bientôt
le soir les volontaires se retrouvent
dans les hôtels bon marché de calcutta
après leur journée de travail ils ont
besoin de partager leurs expériences
mon prix dans leurs rangs
c'est
à un moment donné si j'étais un peu à
part de tout le monde et j'avais les
larmes aux yeux pour voir
tout cet amour qui sont capables de
donner finalement
et puis ils ont pas l'air malheureux du
tout quoi
ce premier soir fanny pascal est clair
se coucheront épuisé
une semaine à passer
il est 6 heures du matin les volontaires
se retrouve avec les soeurs pour la
messe quotidienne
une cérémonie ouverte à tous n'est pas
obligatoire si pierre marie n'en a pas
raté une seule depuis le début de son
séjour
fanny pascal est clair patiente dans une
salle à l'écart réservé aux athées
quelques minutes de répit et chacun va
rejoindre son centre pour une nouvelle
journée de travail
ce matin le frère thomas a choisi le
faire exception à la règle il sent que
ses troupes ont besoin de faire un point
que ce qui est pénible c'est l'attention
qu'il faut apporter aux enfants sayah
promettre genre un show pour cent dans
les starting blocks
mais non sinon c'est bien
il va leur faire faire plusieurs jeux et
tout ça
deux fois par semaine le frère thomas
organise un groupe de parole pour
revenir sur ce que chacun a vécu et
rappeler ici les principes de
l'engagement
[Musique]
dans le dortoir du groupe de jeunes
catholiques ambiance ascétique les
bénévoles ne s'en plaignent pas ils sont
ici pour mettre leur foi à l'épreuve
durant ces séances il faut parler en
toute sincérité
il ya plein de choses plein de tâches
ménagères qu'on n'aimerait pas faire
tout à l'heure il y avait un petit
garçon qui avait fait ses besoins
partout qui fait pipi partout par terre
voilà on a envie de dire les autres les
autres volontaires et allez-y - je
regarde de loin tu as fais pipi c'est
très bien c'est rigolo mais non donc là
j'étais la regardait me diront écrou de
pierre-marie t'y vas t'y vas pas
forcément un moment donné tu te sens tu
prends le jeu prend le ballet tu prends
le jet d'eau je suis accroupi et tu
laves voilà c'est pas obligé d'enlever
mes chaussures parce qu'on pouvait pas
rentrer dans la salle parce qu'il y
avait de l'eau de l'eau par terre mais
après c'est sûr qu'on se dit bon voilà
c'est un victoire victoire sur soi je
crois qu'il faut faire attention
rappelle que vers ceux qui sourient
on peut aller que vers ceux qui soit
beau et et
les balades pour se faire plaisir on est
là pour servir tous les pauvres présent
dans ce centre
ici ils veulent apprendre à ne pas fuir
à dépasser leurs préjugés leurs ports
testant parce qu'il est impossible
de grandes ambitions mais parfois la
confrontation à la réalité peut être
déstabilisante
nous retrouvons fanny elle entame la
deuxième semaine de son séjour elle
alterne toujours entre ménages et
massages après huit jours de travail
elles semblent fatigués et débordé par
l'ampleur de la tâche c'est pas
tellement faire en fait je ne sais pas
par où commencer entre les massages
c'est lui il y en a très très peu
n'arrive même pas à monter jusqu'aux
cuisses avec eux
et puis
piet trop payé 3 faire quoi je me voir
ce que je peux faire
un ruisseau
les centres des missionnaires de la
charité fonctionne grâce aux dons et
avec le minimum de dépenses les soins
sont réalisées avec les moyens du bord
vous avez du savon et la reine tout ça
pour continuer à raser les hommes pascal
doit trouver son matériel et ce n'est
pas toujours une tâche facile
je voulais
je veux races et les patients mais il ya
plus de là mais peu de savon donc bien
qu aucun risque a été chercher dû
acheter du savon et des lames et l'a
peut-être y en a mais ça fait trois fois
qu'on demande
[Musique]
à l'étagé au dessus
fanny l'infirmière se heurtent elle
aussi au manque de moyens et même dit
elle au manque d'attention
elle ose à peine demander de l'aide ou
soeurs
pardon je voudrais lui donner de l'eau
mais elle refuse de boire celles qui ne
veulent pas boire ne leur donnait rien
elles refuseront de toute façon mais
elle a la langue à sécher
elle ne pourra pas tant qu'elle n'aura
pas soif bon d'accord mais
ok
la dame est déshydratée la langue
complètement sèche et demandez comment
faire pour lui faire boire parce qu'elle
refuse djiba l'a jamais soir donc à
bouffe pas et
je fais que ça crée un peu avec cette
chaleur je passe une faune
faut l'hydrater que d'une manière ou
d'une autre ou pas la laisser comme ça
complètement vote y est
[Musique]
elle me dit que c'est pas grave
pour l'infirmière c'est le désarroi et
l'impuissance
à calcutta les premiers jours passés
l'enthousiasmé des volontaires et mise à
l'épreuve
pas facile de tenir dans cette ville
suffocante pas facile non plus
d'accepter certaines frustrations
dix jours après son arrivée claire est
un peu amer elle se demande à quoi elle
sert elle a fini par quitter des enfants
handicapés pour se porter au chevet des
mourants
[Applaudissements]
c'est dans ce centre que mère teresa
avait commencé sa mission auprès des
pauvres au coeur de calcutta elle ne
voulait pas qu'il meure seul mais tous
chez emi soixante ans plus tard les
soeurs déborder délègue totalement cette
tâche aux volontaires
pour la première fois depuis le début de
son séjour claire est autorisé à
participer aux soins elle a réussi à
faire valoir ses compétences d'être
soignante
ça me change un peu du désinfecte âge de
deux lits et cetera
je m'occupe des malades moi non
c'est archaïque un
effet vraiment avec les moyens du bord
et puis comme en temps tu es là toi
trois mois
claire est de plus en plus choqués par
ce qu'elle voit et c'est elle entend
aussi
[Musique]
c'est impressionnant
ça me change tellement de chez nous
c'est
vraiment une autre dimension y'a aucune
notion d'hygiène
ce hallucinant
hélas ces quatre lancements
la fidh et la soeur sens avait les mains
elle a fait autre chose en même temps et
est revenue sur la patiente elle
repartait elle laissait les plus à l'est
106 jeunes du tout pas en fait
suis démoralisé pourquoi parce que je
plains les patients
au lieu de durer deux trois mois
alors qu'elles vont durer peut-être un
emploi
une soeur francophone a saisi quelques
phrases elle nous prie de quitter le
centre aucune des soeurs n'acceptera de
nous parler de répondre aux critiques de
claire
pour la dernière fois elle franchi cette
porte sa décision est prise
on se sent frustré en fait j'ai pas trop
envie de renouveler l'expérience en fait
je suis très déçu maintenant on n'est
pas encore ça
leur but invités avec les gens
j'peux pas du tout maternelle
elles sont pas
je m'attendais pas à ça
[Musique]
dans les rangs des français c'est la
désillusion
fanny et pascal profitent de leurs jours
de congé hebdomadaire le jeudi pour se
reposer et faire le point les voilà
redevenir de simples touristes une
visite d'un tank à proximité de calcutta
à libercourt leur bilan est mitigé ils
ont déjà vécu beaucoup de moments
difficiles
[Musique]
et hop a simplement dit diffusé dès ce
soir le
propriétaire et
non des firmes hier ouais même pour
accompagner une personne qui est en
train de mourir
du confort plus de massage hydrater la
personne c'est vraiment le minimum qu'on
puisse faire est bon quand j'ai vu moi
cette petite fille on hydrate et même
pas pour la changer on l'a retourné
comme un sac de patates j'étais choquée
de voir ça parce que c'est pas bien
c'est pas bien du tout ces derniers
moments à
je comprenais en douceur
donc ça m'a vraiment surpris que j'ai
passé à
parce que donner un toit c'est juste
faire la charité
et ça s'arrête là pour se prendre
je pense que le mrt zac à la craie et ça
c'était pour partager avec les gens à
donner de l'amour on s'aperçoit que ça
celle que perdu
claire et pascal se demandent s'ils ne
vont pas abandonner aussi
à calcutta l'été s'achève
les jeunes catholiques terminent leur
séjour
ils ont vu des hommes mourir d'autres
souffrir et aujourd'hui ils doivent se
séparer de rajesh le jeune toxicomane
que le frère thomas et pierre marie
espérer sauver
ils ont essayé de le convaincre de
rester au centre quelques temps encore
mais rajesh veut partir
pierre marie et le frère thomas n'ont
plus qu'à la compagnie
de rentré à la gare
donc
au lieu d'expliquer les frères vont me
l'expliquer c'est mais ont laissé le
choix de
acheter au centre
pour se reposer pour se soigner pour
repartir à la guerre pour se droguer il
a préféré la drogue
on le ramène c'est son choix
une dernière fois ils vont tenter de le
faire changer d'avis
rajesh là tu vois c'est le dispense
heures
le frère thomas lui rappelle qu'à tout
moment il peut se vendre dans ce
dispensaire près de la gare
tu vas au centre ou à la gare
dernières secondes d'hésitation mais
rajesh ne changera pas d'avis
c'est ici qu'il vit et qu'il travaille
[Applaudissements]
on va pas te lâcher comme ça mon
bonhomme
a lyon tout de suite
rajesh vie sur un quai de gare en
compagnie d'une bande de gamins des rues
sa famille en quelque sorte qu'il
retrouve
les volontaires eux n'arrivent pas à
partir allez les six
parce que même si les enfants sourit
parce qu'ils sont contents de se
retrouver et ben voilà c'est inhumain de
laisser des gens
pourrir sur une gare
[Applaudissements]
soudain à l'écart pierre-marie de crack
[Musique]
le voir repartir et sachant qu' il va
reprendre la drogue russe l'effet de
l'alcool ait eu besoin d'états
pathétique après on se dit que l'aide
qu'on lui a apporté va finalement les
minimes elle a été de courte durée nous
on aurait voulu clairement les centres
pour se faire soigner et pour essayer de
retrouver une vie normale et là il
retourne à la garde des petits boulots
travailler ce qui fait de l'un la drogue
seule raison de vivre
c'est pour moi
[Musique]
on joue à plein
quelques mois après son retour en france
pierre-marie nous a confié que cette
expérience l'avait changé et qu'il
pensait souvent à ses enfants
qu'il avait laissé derrière lui
il s'appelle me de revenus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fanny et pascal se sont accrochés
finalement ils ont fini par se porter
volontaire auprès des enfants là où il
se sentait le plus utile
malgré les déceptions ont préféré se
souvenir des belles choses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à son retour en france fanny a décidé de
travailler avec les enfants handicapés
à
simone infatigable promet de revenir
l'été prochain pour soulager celle
qu'elle appelle ses amis et les écouter
chanter encore
m
[Musique]
elle devait avoir une belle voix mais
à la guerre de calcutta rajesh à ses
copains ont repris leur vie entre drogue
et jeux d'enfants en partant
pierre-marie leur avait offert cette
petite voiture en bois elle est là ils
savent que quelqu'un se souvient d'eux
[Musique]